all right let's do this let's get into
it let's go back into it I forget where
we are do I have to run away is the
first thing I have to do when I get back
in this game run away oh I'm here wait
wait oh that's not good okay so I have
the hand I have the night vision I have
a key so I've got pretty much everything
I need what I can do is I can go south
whoa whoa whoa whoa what the what the
what the what the what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] how are you here well I knew I
needed to run for some reason I just
didn't know from what or why okay
I'm in I'm in trouble I'm in very much
trouble I'm in so much trouble I'm in
trouble I'm in trouble
I'm in trouble I need it I need to take
the ring off
and put the mask on and go I need to go
hit the button here we go
I hope you're not in here Billy okay
that's five to six no I'm not able to go
through those doors no that's not fair
that's not fair that's not fair I think
oh I oh I you see i oh i y-yes are you
[Music]
are you not now
hello hi oh [ __ ] he's gonna pop out at
any minute now he's gonna get me get me
oh [ __ ]
no not now
this is literally the worst thing
they're gonna happen at this juncture at
this point in time I don't know where I
am I don't know where I'm going
Tesla gate perfect
zap that [ __ ] that that [ __ ] oh yeah
gives you act sorry buddy that's just
the way it goes around here you dunzo in
a funs oh but you done though okay holy
[ __ ] oh boy what is that oh I don't want
to go down there okay I don't have
enough for any of this I need to drop
this or something take this put it here
grab the battery again no not the paper
no not that Oh grab the paper no got the
battery there we go okay what is this
scorch note oh this is just I've read
that before I don't think it's anything
useful okay I haven't saved since I came
over here but I have a bad feeling that
that dude is just gonna keep following
me until he gets me so I think I have to
go down here but I have a night-vision
goggle thing oh that's very comforting
all the loud booms and bangs are very
definitely comforting
no no no yeah what was bad what was not
okay not okay let me just oh my god let
me just I want to get to a save point
that's what I want there's a dead body
that's great
I just want to try to get to a save
point
[Music]
what Wow Wow
what the [ __ ] no how did you get
there what is on it oh [ __ ] I don't know
where this goes but I'm gonna go this
way cuz I got nothing else to do what
the [ __ ] hell and [ __ ] a duck
close it good where am i what close it
what the [ __ ] what the what the [ __ ] oh
hi oh hey how you doing um oh god [ __ ]
Oh dick
Oh dick dick dick dick dick dick dick
dick dick dick dick dick dick greetings
greetings fellow human greetings
greetings greetings need to get some
goddamn distance on you okay and Skoosh
and then take up this is my help this
hell is hell on earth is hell is hell
what happens if he goes through a Tesla
gate come on come on [ __ ] you want to
play huh
let's go
oh my god
as you get past a test okay okay
good thing I have my vision right sure
is good there we go even better okay
[Music]
[ __ ] this shit's good it's so weird how
this game can still make you scared
I've been playing this game since the
beginning in my channel it's still
[ __ ] terrifies me what is this lead
anywhere oh is that is this is this um
okay okay okay what is that I don't know
what that is I'm taking it
let's stain note God in heaven hell I
don't know oh this is the bing-bong Bell
what the [ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is
that you can fix this go away
wait perhaps it's time is up wait hey oh
hi oh god oh god oh god
what do I do I can't no no no I can't do
anything about that no no no no no no
God [ __ ] man no listen listen you don't
want to do any of it
just let me laugh just let me live just
let me live
[Music]
I just gotta I just gotta hope I can get
around him where are you you were here
you're not okay I can get around let's
open that I have a high enough clearance
for this yes I got [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
no don't do swipes like that come on
what are you doing we showed you in here
yes you get shut in there okay you're
shut in there I'm not even gonna read
that I need a screen I need to save now
I need to save right the [ __ ] now I
cannot wait it cannot wait I have to
save right now it cannot wait please
screen oh my god give me a screen
[Music]
[Music]
eyedrops
dad's doesn't help that's not a screen
what is this level three we already have
that there's a med kit here okay kid yes
please I guess I'll take that it's not
where I want to be okay man they made
the doctor so much more of a problem
can't believe that open actually
[Music]
they're still kind of far away put this
just in case I need to run nope not
doing that whatever was in there I
didn't want to be any part of it give me
something okay that's
[Music]
[Applause]
no no no no what is that what is that
what is that what is what the can you
wonder what am I looking at wait I can't
get ha ha [ __ ] [ __ ] oh not this but
maybe is it is there a is there is there
a um is our computer screen in here
somewhere
[ __ ] dicks dick dick dick dick dick dick
ok it's just 1 7 3 near me right there
now I don't know what this is Oh gasps
yep pretty accurate thank you
oh you're gone okay thank you for huh
why why what the [ __ ] is that
what is that what the [ __ ] is that I
heard footage Debbie's we're a my god
damn it I keep getting turned around the
[ __ ] invisible what's the deal what is
the deal I can't see [ __ ] I hear it
though I definitely hear it it is there
something's there something I've never
seen before
it's not showing up on the radar Oh 49
is still there but that's a tweet was
over for an eye on the doctor please
tell me o49 is a doctor
[Music]
what does this lead to
SCP o49 that is him what is that
DNA does not match I have this Oh
well that worked okay okay where is this
I see people it's the same thing I don't
know where I am but I don't want to go
down that's for goddamn sure go on just
give me a goddamn screen please I'm
begging you
all I need is a screen oh my god did I
somehow make a big circle I did didn't I
oh please just give me a screen of some
kind all right well if that is the
doctor then I'm just gonna go down cuz I
mean this is how you would bypass this
thing but maybe there's a screen down
there I think I remember very vaguely
[Music]
cani looks important let me just hope I
haven't dropped anything of value
oh you can make key give me the key give
me the key you can be the key thank you
alright well this sucks
pipe or is that our body that's a body
alright please tell me there's a screen
in here I can save on screen work none
of these work they changed this whatever
this is I know those guys are gonna get
up and be zombies I know that I know
that's how that works I ain't going in
there please oh god none of these what
is that level 4 okay that's good good
thing I went down here no not that god
no god damn it
it's right there give it okay all right
I don't know what's going on I want out
I know for a fact I want out okay I got
turn on the generator that's what I get
it dad turned on the generator oh there
they go okay I'm just gonna gun it for
the elevator just gonna gun it just
gonna cut it Wow why you sack of [ __ ]
you sack of [ __ ] you sack of [ __ ]
okay I'm gonna get around you're gonna
say oh you're not no you're not you're
not the curia master get the [ __ ] now
this is not how I die this is not how I
die stop bad touch bad touch bad bad
touch bad touch bad touch bad touch bad
touch metouch please let me go will you
living out a little further
I'm running now I'm running not here
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]